I need a steady [ __ ] girlfriend man  it's a dangerous dangerous thing to say  I understand we have someone new in our  class this morning so so late in the  semester I know did you see that new  chicken  [Music]  hi the one on the bus is pirates like  the animal the other is Andy awesome ski  all us to do is get loaded jackoff  other dicks and goals I don't know any  better they're entirely unreliable  accessibility matters I wrote Mandy -  love letter we all make mistakes  we're gonna go after Mandy where were  you last night I was at the beach with  ending  hey weasel oospeed Mandi Myers is a [ __ ]  and a [ __ ] how the hell did you get all  these chicks anyway last time that  surgery Friday and  Saturday since then my dick has been  completely left  [Music]  and if they say while Southern Cali  girls use your girlfriend viciously to  turn it was my turn [ __ ]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]